now if I were to find out if I would
assure that and by sex PR and and by sex
2s and well then what a ways I could do
that is by proving that P and is equal
to F up that would be most likely equal
to your Greek at the same time I
couldn't is not the same time afterwards
I would then prove that when I got down
to butter Q M equals and yes that would
do the job would this okay but boy that
would be a pain someone tell me why
choosing this part to be the question
would be a grand take any takers
well you ready what where is M where is
M what is the definition of him it's the
and it's the point of intersection of
these two diagonals right it's the point
of intersection of these aisles I don't
know it is the middle yet that's what
I'm supposed to prove do you agree that
right so even though I'm looking at it
and I've even calling it an even
suggested time the middle I can't assume
that that is the case so I have to show
that where these puts when he is willing
to say at that point how do I find where
two lines intersect let's find a normal
way of doing that I'm going to have to
solve something simultaneously what you
have to solve so truthful if christmas
dared anybody though yeah you're going
to enjoy this equation right they need
to know this equation that you sold
simultaneously put your hand up if you
want to do that right
firstly I don't even know what this
equation is come on go find it I put
these two points right so which form of
the equation of lunch and I used it I've
got two points or three days I would
probably choose two point four because I
have two points right I'm going to do
the same thing er and then once I've got
those equations which by the way look
like they're going to be disastrous once
I've got those two equations then I'm
going to have to solve simultaneously
I've my head hurts just thinking about
it
okay look you've got so many different
created by ground eight of them this is
just going to be a disaster it will
still work you think get to here and it
will be true but it's a very inefficient
way to go so it doesn't that make sense
sort the better way that's a better way
this point here I'm alleging it's the
midpoint of PR that's what I'm alleging
right if it's also the bisector of this
it will be the diagonal and it should be
the midpoint of this set of corners as
well right I might show that then same
what is the midpoint of team up the
midpoint of PR what is it now I keep
going towards this right
I love midpoints because midpoints are
so easy to work out right as compared to
equations of lines as opposed to
distances these are all hard to work out
but midpoints you can just sort of state
them right have a look look at the
corners keep your status formula for me
what would it look like in this case
it's going to be this corner this corner
I've got an admin right X 1 plus X 2 on
2 plus 1 X 3 plus X 4 all right also on
2 you've added that and then you device
I'll take in the average right have a
look at the y-coordinates the
y-coordinates are going to be exactly
the same okay
y 1 plus y 2 y 3 + y 4 and then I now
admittedly that looks messy our exercise
just looks long it's not messy it's not
complicated
what happens when you add these two
fractions they even obtain denominator
so what's going to happen then you ready
is just going to combine together now
both of these are over - but then you're
subsequently going to divide by two so
what's the new denominator yeah
the Y's are exactly the same you almost
don't even have to think this is one of
the nice things about midpoints cache to
compile it any further
you can you know do anything about X 1 X
2 X 3 X 4 etc that's that's done ok this
is the midpoint of now just look look at
the other diagonal what they call get qf
q s do I even need to go about the next
slide have a look at the things you're
going to be adding together right
instead of X 1 X 2 then X 3 X 4 you have
the same pieces they just appeared a
different order
do you see that right there's X 1 X 4 is
X 2 X 3 I'm going to just write out
exactly the same words end up with the
same thing right
which I'll let you two do to show that
the midpoint of PR is indeed the
midpoint of Q s so if you've got two
intervals and the midpoints are the same
place right there for P R and Q s what
was that phrase I had before what they
do to each other they been mutually by
sense right
okay you don't need to fuss around with
any gradients or distances anymore
that's it therefore pqrs is it has to be
a parallelogram because this property
here of diagram diagonals mutually
bisecting is a property that both we
parallelograms have which is why
subsequently rectangles have the
rhombuses have the square type them
because they're all just fancy versions
of parallelograms does that make sense
diagonals usually my sense okay so
what's happen quit if you don't like
what that sod you how would you even do
this now one of my other favorite ways
to prove this is using something called
vectors unfortunately at this point you
guys don't know practice I'm sorry you
might have heard of it they just think
that indicate distance and also
direction the vector person is is
particularly led but because we're going
to access to those tools yet this is
pretty good right there are other ways
to do it you can also make you can also
drop inquisitor like parallel lines
because there are so many other similar
triangles but I'm not going to go there
because that also takes intuitive and
fine but there you go this is the use of
quality geometry tools to do deductive
geometry proofs usually those are two
separate things right you know how if
you get asked Oh show that show that
this triangle here that gives name a b c
it is similar to this triangle over here
a X Y you don't used to see it
coordinate so funny like this right but
that's what we're sort of moving into
now it's all the same tools that you use
before thinking about a parallelogram
thinking about its properties and how to
go about that but through the lens of
quarter geometry here you can straight
line it in them